alors j'aimerais que vous fermiez les yeux et
que vous imaginiez que vous êtes dans un ascenseur un large
ascenseur avec des murs de velours et des
tapis épais et à mesure que les portes se ferment vos
paupières deviennent plus lourdes et à mesure que vos yeux
deviennent plus lourds et que l'ascenseur commence
à vous descendre  réalisez que c'est l'
ascenseur de la relaxation et maintenant vous êtes
au troisième étage en train de descendre et vous pouvez
sortir mais vous voulez aller plus
loin plus profondément dans la relaxation et vous
sentez que vous ne voudrez peut-être jamais
sortir c'est tellement  en sécurité ici si confortable
si détendu Je ne veux plus parler à Simon
mais je veux parler aux hommes
qui écoutent